[موسيقى]
اتهامات للدعم السريع بالتمركز في
مستشفيات الخرطوم
صوره مزيفه لانفجار البنتاجون تتسبب بهبوط
البورصه
تضامن عالمي واسع مع اللاعب فينيسيوس ضد
العنصريه
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
ونبدا من السودان وفي اخر التطورات
الميدانيه اتهمت وزاره الصحه في ولايه
الخرطوم قوات الدعم السريع بالتمركز في
المستشفيات الوزاره اوضحت في بيان لها ان
قوات الدعم واصلات الاستهداف المستمر
للقطاع الصحي بكل مكوناته واستهداف المرضى
والكوادر الصحيه مشيره الى انها تتمركز
بداخل 28 مستشفى وست مؤسسات صحيه حيويه
اخرى والاستيلاء على احدى عشرين عربه
اسعاف فيما سمعت اصوات معارك وغارات جويه
في العاصمه الخرطوم رغم دخول اتفاق جديد
لوقف اطلاق النار بين الطرفين حيز التنفيذ
[موسيقى]
تسببت صوره مزيفه انتشرت على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي الانفجار في البنتاغون
تسببت بتراجع البورصه لبضع دقائق قبل ان
تنفي وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه صحه هذا
الانفجار ناطق باسم وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه اوضح ان ما نشر خبر كاذب وان
البنتا لم يتعرض لهجوم فيما رجح خبراء امن
تكنولوجي لصحيفه واشنطن تايمز ان تكون
الصوره نتاجا للذكاء الاصطناعي التوليدي
وهو ما يسلط الضوء مجددا على المشاكل
الكثيره التي يمكن ان تسببها هذه
التكنولوجيا المتقدمه من اضرار اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه
بعد ان اثارت جدلا واسعا داخل الاوساط
المصريه نفت القاهره رسميا ما تردد عن
ارسال توابيت فرعونيه الى اسرائيل لفحصها
رئيس هو قطاع المتاحف بالمجلس الاعلى
للاثار مؤمن عثمان اكد في تصريحات صحفيه
عدم خروج اي قطع اثريه من المتاحف المصريه
للفحص او الدراسه بالخارج في قد ترددت
اخبار عن نقل اغطيه توابيت يتجاوز عمرها
الاف السنين لاجراء فحص بالاشعه المقطعيه
في مستشفى اسرائيلي زعمت انها من اجل
التعرف على العمليات التي قام بها
الحرفيون اثناء تصنيع الاغذيه منذ الاف
السنين
بعد مرور يومين على تعرض النجم البرازيليه
فينيسيوس جونيور لاساءه العنصريه جديده
اعلنت الشرطه الاسبانيه اليوم اعتقال
اربعه اشخاص على خلفيه التحقيق في شنق
دميه بقميص فينيسيوس وهذا على جسر في
مدريد خلال شهر يناير الماضي وكان مهاجم
ريال مدريد تعرض لاساءات عنصريه جديده
اثناء مباراه فريقه مع فالنسيا ضمن دوري
كره القدم الاسباني واثارت هذه الحادثه
تضامنا واسعا مع فينيسيوس عالميا فيما
اخطات البرازيل اضواء تمثال المسيح
الايقوني في ريو دي جينيرو لمده ساعه
واحده مساء الاثنين لاظهار التضامن مع
فينيسيوس
وفي خبرنا الاخير رفع التيك توك دعوه
قضائيه امام محكمه فيدراليه لمنع تطبيق
قانون اقرته ولايه مونتانا الامريكيه تحضر
بموجبه منصه الفيديو الشهيره اعتبارا من
مطلع العام 2024 تيك توك اشارت في دعواها
الى ان هذا الحظر غير المسبوق يتعارض مع
حريه التعبير في الدستور الامريكي وعرب
الناطق باسم تيك توك عن ثقته بالنجاح في
المواجهه القضائيه هذه فيما اصبحت مونتانا
اول ولايه امريكيه تحضر تطبيق تيك توك
عندما وقع حاكمها الجمهوري على القانون
الذي سيعاقب كل مزودي التطبيق من المتاجر
الالكترونيه
[موسيقى]